Speaker 1: One of the biggest successes and of
paramount importance for what Joe Biden has done
in this presidency so far is something
that has barely made headlines. And it
is that Joe Biden has confirmed more judges
than Trump, Obama and George W Bush at this
point in their respective presidencies. It is
not the Supreme Court. That's absolutely true.
But it is of massive, massive importance. Business
Insider and others talking about this, how
Biden outdid Trump, Obama and George W Bush
in confirming federal judges by this point
in office, a feat overshadowed by war and
inflation. And it has been. Joe Biden has
confirmed more federal judges at this point
in his tenure than any president since JFK.
Biden's court picks have also been the most
racially, ethnically and gender diverse.
But his judicial wins have been overshadowed by
news of inflation, war and the FBI. Mar a Lago
Search. This is a major, major deal. As of August
8th, which was 566 days into Biden's tenure,
the Senate had already confirmed a record setting
75 judges nominated by Biden to federal courts,
according to the Pew Research Center.
Trump didn't do that. Obama didn't do
that. George W Bush didn't have those numbers.
You have to go back to JFK, who at this point
in his presidency, we're talking about the
sixties. Folks had confirmed 102 judges
as of August 26. Joe Biden had gone from 75 to
78, and that includes appeals and district court
judges, along with one Supreme Court justice.
This is interesting because, I mean, listen,
Biden is not incorrectly seen as boring and
milquetoast. It's just what it is. In a sense,
you could make the case that that's exactly
what the country needed to sort of recover from
Donald Trump, a guy who every day was ridiculing
a disabled journalist, drawing with a Sharpie on a
hurricane map. I'm not going to give you the list
that I'd have to sit here for 5 hours giving you
the list. And when you take a guy who's you could
say his the reasons many people didn't like Biden
include he's been in D.C. for a generation
and he's not exciting in the sense that
certain candidates are. And I
want to be careful here because
some of these aren't really criticisms, but
they were used as criticisms during the primary.
Relatively centrist seeming, but actually on paper
was the most progressive Democratic nominee that I
can remember. I mean, on paper, Biden was to the
left of Barack Obama. The things that Joe Biden
has done and there are many criticisms of there
are many criticisms of the Biden administration.
Without a doubt. I mean, every presidency has
criticisms, but quietly forgiving more student
loan debt than any president in history, quietly
getting more judges confirmed at this point in his
presidency than any president dating back to John
F Kennedy. In a sense, you could argue that this
was maybe exactly what was needed to get out of or
to recover from Donald Trump. Someone completely
predictable, right. I mean, this was I kept saying
during the primary, all of these people saying
Biden's going to be some secret right winger.
Or Biden's going to be some secret communist.
Never believable. But the people on the right were
saying that no, Biden was going to be a completely
predictable center left Democrat who on paper is
the most left leaning Democratic nominee, at least
in in many, many decades. And that's what it's
worked out to be. And so I can give you my list
of the things I would love for Joe Biden to do
that he hasn't done. What happened to health care
reform? What about decriminalizing cannabis? What
about of course, we can always come up with a list
of things we would like presidents to do that they
have not done. But it is starting to be remarkable
the amount that actually has been accomplished and
much of it with extraordinarily little fanfare.
And I have to say this. This isn't like gushing
praise. It's just sort of a trait of Joe Biden.
He does it without the self-centered bombast of
somebody like Donald Trump. And when you expect,
because of the Trump era, a president to
be tooting his own horn, or you could use
more graphic metaphors than that if you want
about the things that they have accomplished.
Trump did it about things he didn't even
really do. Right. We built the wall. No,
you didn't. What are you talking about? You didn't
build the wall anyway because Joe Biden doesn't
do that. I think that's part of why many of these
accomplishments have been have been quietly done.
And also that stories like Ukraine, inflation and
others have pervaded the news to a greater degree.
So I'm as curious as anybody else. Where will
Joe Biden's approval be on midterm Election Day
in just eight or nine weeks? And what impact will
that have on Democrats ability to hold the Senate?
And although it's less likely potentially hold
hold the House and we'll update those numbers
for you later this week. Remember that this
Wednesday, August 31st, 6 p.m. Eastern, we're
doing a member only David Pakman show town hall.
This will be limited in terms of participation to
our website members. Anybody can watch. It will
be streaming live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook
at 6 p.m. Eastern. Only our website members
will be invited to participate in this one.
And you can add yourself to that exclusive group
of people by signing up at join Packman dot com.